trevor williams looking for win number
one in his third start
a couple fastballs to kepler
pops up and yes you're good you're good
you're good and
jorge polanco he's good at bats
and with the three infielders on the
right side eddie rosario
3-2 and hit in the air to right polanco
no good work trevor williams randy
dobneck
will be on the hill facing his hometown
team for the first time in his
career
left field and rosario calls for it one
away
rise flips two down
it's pretty hard to center going back is
cave
and he makes the catch on the edge of
the track at that
the twins logo swung so hard it it's off
kilter
kurt's swinging out of your helmet
swinging out of your shoes he literally
swung out of the logo yeah
runner goes and bounced left side
what a pick what a play
by gonzalez oh man
i guess that's do or die mitch garver
and he gets a chase marwin gonzalez
he he already swung his logo off zero
logo
how about that oh you're right
what's going on
that's down the left field line chased
by gonzalez and that's
a fair ball we believe it is a
reviewable play
first base in the run scores yes justice
prevails
full count to the leadoff man here in
the second
oh well why waste the first five pitches
when you're gonna give up a bullet
you stick out the glove
and arise throws him out a great play by
luisa rise in short right field
[Applause]
gonna bring it for hey polanco line
into a double play so brakes do go both
ways
bring up josh bell oh
yeah the other way still carrying
and off the padded wall bell gonna have
to hustle
and he is there with a double moran
lined out to center
and he got the strikeout two down
well that ball was right over the middle
not where he wanted to throw it but
gonzalez and the pick on the other end
by josh bell they call it the hot corner
for the reason i mean we talked about in
the pregame
everybody that's played third base been
absolutely raking but that's why they
actually call it the hot corner
cole tucker hit a little nubber up the
line runner goes
swung out in mid and they got him in
second base
good throw by garber good tag by polanco
a little hit and run right there one one
now top of the order max kepler
and again but can't hit the waterfall
the waterfall
doing the job tonight can you get nelson
cruz a third time
and he gets the chase he went back he
thought he was kind of hurrying a little
bit
took his time thought about it comes
back and gets the fastball past him what
a job tonight from trevor williams
six shutout innings a happy homecoming
for randy dobneck
and arise dumps one down the line that's
a fair ball and a hit
and a rise going for second
and he's in with a double
and i was going to say marwin's ball he
hit off the pine tar that one arise just
kind of
threw the barrel at it and the 1-0 pitch
is swinging a fly ball
to left near the line adrion's in the
foul territory runs it down with a
backhand snag
nothing routine about that twins had a
shift out andreyans had to cover a ton
of ground
two and two bases loaded two outs
one-nothing twins eighth inning
chopped right side bell there and that
will do it jeff hartley
and the 3-2 swag and a miss he got him
on a breaking ball
so duffy strikes out two more now ten
strikeouts
in five scoreless innings
here's buxton breaking ball hammer down
the line how many bases
it'll go into the corner
[Applause]
and buxton glides into second with a
double and busting
starts the ninth inning with an extra
base hit see what can
gonzalez can do here into left center
field
and the veteran delivers buxton will
score
and gonzalez delivers a big rbi
single here in the night two down and
now it's up to max
high blast to right field back
and gone a home run for kepler
and the lead grows to five to nothing
josh bell two of the three pirates hits
in the air to center hit deep
and ring your bell bush time
finish off the ball game did he go
strike three and the game is over
alkala finishes it the pirates get a
couple
but your minnesota twins have won six in
a row